I remember I was telling you guys at one time my freshman year,
I didn't take her shit for a week and a half.
I used to,
I was addicted to steak.
Comes from American.
Jeez and all right.
A French bro.
Listen to me.
I was in,
I played freshman ball and we were playing Paddison east side.
That's just a jungle of a school.
Like you gotta be careful when you go in there.
And uh,
we went there to play the Christmas tournament.
Well,
what kind of ball are we talking about?
Basketball and I hadn't taken a shift from like 10 days or something.
I took acid,
something.
Fuck my stomach.
I didn't tell nobody.
No Way.
Home.
We got on the bus
and while we were waiting there,
my stomach started hurting.
I said,
Jesus Christ,
I don't know if I'm going to shoot myself a Fart,
but let me just take a chance.
And I blew this far.
Joe Rogan,
that was so bad,
right?
We want a bus.
And people started running,
you know,
the school buses,
people started running to the window is right to swing down the bus windows.
But here's what you got by the Ifr that again,
the teachers are going,
oh my God,
he's changing flavors.
What's the worst thing was the cheerleaders are crying.
That's how bad they were sitting in front of a bus.
One of the teachers yell,
does my God,
he's changing.
That's how bad these parts.
We don't mind.
He's changing your whole bus dog fight was fucking God awful.
I wrote a blog about one to Joyce farts ones.
Does that on a plane?
Yes.
They got rid of that.
Okay.